[Música]
nos encantan los fuegos artificiales las
luces los colores y esa gran
explosión pero mucho antes de esos
fuegos artificiales épicos unos químicos
chinos inventaron el ingrediente clave
que impulsa esas luces brillantes hacia
el
cielo esa invención fue lo que ahora
llamamos polvo
esta historia se remonta a la antigua
China A mediados del siglo ix cuando los
primeros alquimistas chinos trataban de
crear una poción de la inmortalidad en
cambio crearon un polvo inflamable que
quemó Muchas de sus casas rápidamente
advirtieron que este polvo negro al que
llamaron medicina de fuego era
Precisamente lo contrario a algo que los
hiciera vivir para siempre los chinos
aún no habían descubierto Cómo hacer
explotar al polvo simplemente era muy
inflamable y sus ejércitos lo usaban
para hacer flechas incendiarias o
lanzallamas pero al descubrir las
proporciones de ingredientes para
generar una explosión lo empezaron a
usar aún más y crearon fuegos
artificiales para mantener alejados a
los Espíritus malignos y bombas para
defenderse de los mongoles y fueron
estos mongoles quienes difundieron la
invención de la pólvora por el mundo
después de interceptar los ataques
chinos aprendieron a producir pólvora
por sí mismos y la llevaron consigo en
sus conquistas en pers e India Guillermo
de rub un embajador europeo ante los
mongoles fue el responsable de llevar la
pólvora a Europa en
1254 a partir de allí ingenieros e
inventores militares crearon todo tipo
de armas de destrucción mediante bombas
armas y cañones la pólvora dejó su marca
en el mundo de maneras terribles en
contraste con las marcas hermosas que
deja en el aire Entonces cómo impulsa el
polvo negro Los fuegos artificiales al
cielo puede que hayas visto pelí o
dibujos animados en los que se enciende
un reguero de pólvora que conduce a un
barril grande y explosivo cuando el
fuego llega al barril ocurre una gran
explosión Pero por qué no explota el
propio reguero la razón es que la
combustión del polvo libera energía y
gases mientras arde el reguero estos se
liberan al aire circundante pero cuando
la pólvora está contenida en el barril
la energía y los gases no pueden escapar
y se acumulan hasta que
Bom el contenedor de fuegos artificiales
proporciona una salida hacia arriba para
canalizar esta energía explosiva la
Mecha enciende la pólvora y la energía
toma la salida más fácil del contenedor
y lanza el fuego artificial alto en el
cielo la llama se abre camino por el
interior del contenedor y se produce la
misma reacción bien
arriba así si bien los alquimistas
chinos nunca encontraron el compuesto de
la vida eterna hallaron algo que daría
forma a toda la civilización algo que ha
provocado muchos momentos trágicos en la
historia Hum y aún así nos da Esperanza
cuando al festejar miramos un colorido
cielo
[Música]
nocturno suscríbase a este canal para
satisfacer su curiosidad con más
lecciones
interesantes